Speaker 1: . Let's go. Let's go next to
Brandon from North Carolina. Brandon,
welcome to the program.
Brandon from North Carolina, you are
muting yourself right now. It's a self
mute. As soon as you unmute yourself,
you'll be able to hear me. Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Hello, David. Nice to talk to you.
Speaker 1: Likewise. Let's go, Brandon.
Speaker 2: So, yeah, I just
was wanting to ask you.
Speaker 1: Whoa, Brandon. Brandon, wait
a second. You're. You're shot out of a
cannon. Can you move the microphone a
little bit further from your mouth or.
Speaker 2: Sorry.
Speaker 1: That's better.
That's smoother. I like that.
Speaker 2: Okay. Is that okay?
So you can hear me better?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Much better.
Speaker 2: Okay. So he has wanted to ask
you. So what's your mind? Think about
the whole Alvin Bragg not wanting
to prosecute Trump on his finances.
Speaker 1: I have not read much about that.
Is Alvin Bragg, was that the New York D.A.,
that it led to two investigators
quitting because they were like,
this is going nowhere. Our work is pointless.
Speaker 2: Yeah, he's the Southern District.
Speaker 1: Ah, I see it here. Yeah. Listen,
at the time when that was. That was news.
It seemed to me that it was obvious that that
was going on to some degree. We've been saying
for a while, it seems that nobody wants to be the
first to prosecute Trump, and we'll see if federal
charges end up being the first thing. Here is my
view on it. If the facts say that a prosecution
is correct, not prosecuting is a cop out and it's
cowardly. Now, that being said, that being said,
we only want to bring charges against anyone,
random people or a former president when the
evidence supports it. So it's not prosecute
Trump because I think Trump's a terrible
president. It's if that's what the evidence
says should be done, it should be done. And
not doing it is a real problem.
Speaker 2: BE Absolutely.
Speaker 1: All right. How are things
otherwise in North Carolina? Oh.
Speaker 2: Pretty good. Then are. Both sides
are words and infrastructure is pretty good, but
other than that, pretty good. Beasley's
And also as long as we don't like.
Speaker 1: What's wrong with the
roads, is it like potholes or what?
Speaker 2: Yeah, potholes like our
roads are pretty much just, like,
crumbling. You can literally just see the
way or on them like this. You can just see
that the wear and tear on them, it's pretty bad.
Speaker 1: That's horrible. That's horrible. All
right. Brandon Will, thank you for the call.
Speaker 2: Thank you very
much. Take it easy, David.
Speaker 1: YouTube. There's Brandon
from North Carolina. Let's take a quick break and
get right back to the callers. If you're holding
on to talk to me, hold on just a moment longer,
because we're going right back to the phones